schon die dann sagt mit denen geht es
also ich habe nichts dagegen wenn man
hat den bildungsetat um 17 prozent
ausland schon so gedacht wird wird
weitermacht glaube ich früher als später
war es für mich sowieso schon vorbei mit
beispiel es ist so dass bei der vergabe
aber nicht weil sie seien
meine damen und herren bei 485 köpfen
letzten wahlkampf hat übrigens toni
sie treffen weil es viel zu wenig ist
weil uni dass er hier ein bisschen auf
doch ebenso kann jeder so leben können
wichtige arbeiten der liegen bleiben
sind also 1000 quadratmeter wie einst
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
der politik zu hinterfragen herzlich
ändern das glaub ich hab sie werden also
wochen hat das rad und eine ganz dicke
willkommen zurück bei 48 schön dass sie
hofreiter von den grünen den bau von
nicht mehr wir leben ja nicht in
wenn es sinn macht
weil es war es so daneben das ist eines
dass frau merkel die ukraine also dass
gekürzt was sagen sie dazu
dem wegweiser in der firma für kinder
dass die ukraine nicht in das bündnis
sicherlich nur beim nicht nur beim daily
gerhard schröder dann sozusagen
wie er will also wie das von ihnen
und das sind alles leute die was bauen
die metaebene gezogen hat dann muss man
einfachen zeiten wir müssen das machen
also ich sag mal so das lag jetzt nicht
herren zu viertel nach acht ist es
büro gemeinde kann sich ja mal
das geld wurde jetzt bereitgestellt was
sind meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
dran geblieben sind wir machen direkt
eigenheimen scharf kritisiert und jetzt
dieses einen panzer ist auch die
tutti das an was haben wir nicht so gut
oder sowas ist doch kein mensch mehr als
frau und er muss motorrad lamprecht
schülerinnen und schüler sagt dann sind
tja es wäre jetzt nicht meine priorität
dann kommt schon so ein moment wo ein
abgegeben hat aber am schluss ist
ist in pr maschen und den leuten ist
ja auch eins mal sagen ich meine die
hervor dass die firma mattel auch noch
mittwochabend und es erwarten sie fünf
telegraph so gedacht sondern es gibt
wollen und zwar ein haus bauen wollen
weiter mit der these von béla anda heute
ich mich aber manchmal frage braucht es
thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt ärgert
aufgenommen wird george bush der
sie in die un aufgenommen werden müssen
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
ansteckender als omnicom baa2 zu sein
mein eindruck ist dass herr merz auch
schwangere frau im neunten monat hätte
nachfragen oder hat tut wahrscheinlich
gefahren aber die haben sich ja auch im
unbedingt daran weil wir jetzt so stark
steiniger
selbst ihnen etwas wohlhabenderen
ministers vollkommen unwürdig ein
stößt die bundesbauministerium ins
bundeskanzler sich die frage steht nützt
damit nicht geholfen und es war dass es
nämlich ja das ist voll in die
überall probleme was das ansehen
leidenschaftliche debatten über die
2008 in die nato in die nato aufgenommen
sozusagen 40 jahren diese das ist ihrer
sogenannten experten herzlich willkommen
oder ihre wohnung modernisierung was
abend janina vielen dank ich habe mich
einmal war ich schon gesagt wir haben
geld oder braucht es auch besseres
amerikanische präsident wollte das
freut oder schockiert
gewesen wären sondern ich glaube er dass
ich kann sagen dass ich im deutschen
armee was auch immer der lieben frau
drin personal glaube ich insgesamt an
gegenden sondern es werden kleinere
scheint niemand hört das gerne aber es
manuell in das offizielles wort anbietet
berechnung aber sozusagen wir meinen
letzten wahlkampf nicht komplett dagegen
emotionalen themen die deutschland
also ich finde dass der gesamte spd teil
gleiche verbot sein ich finde statt
der mir noch oder schadet der mir und
damals unbedingt und angela merkel hat
kein wert darauf legt in dieser
deutschlands angeht und wenn die
außer zwei glaube ich sehr dürren
management ich habe mir angeschaut nicht
immer und es ist einfach zu wenig diese
bundes nicht
eine chancenungleichheit gibt in
grundstücksparzellen mit einem kleinen
werden und hätten werden müssen so wie
minister muss eine art von konsens
die spd trotz der schlecht der eigenen
der verständigen aufsicht von leuten die
so nicht über chip buschi hergiswil
aufgeregt eigentlich das ganze
dass sich kunst sprache kunst ist wahre
unwürdig
gestellt als union gegen das zu ändern
ministerin vorgeworfen wird die ist doch
situation mit diesem krieg kanzler zu
bewegen meine großartigen gäste heute
statements bisher nichts von ihr gehört
verteidigungsministerin urlaub macht ich
verbote sollte es finanzielle anreize
der punkt ist noch nicht erreicht aber
andersrum ist meine priorität werden
schlecht eigentlich unser etat ist und
ist so dass corona virus bleibt
eisern dagegen gestanden hat es
sehen sie das denn jahr 2008 noch gar
wochenende ist schon aufgeregt über
herstellen wollen dass er ein land auch
garten oder so aber trotzdem bleibt
regierung hat und die das wirst du dir
deutschland aber solche pr gags helfen
mit gender sternchen nämlich putin
oder weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
was von der sache verstehen also wir
als stärkung der adelhauser inzwischen
nicht im zustand weil sie seit drei
zu eingangs diese von uli vielleicht
werden also ein bisschen leisetreter
wir werden irgendwann dahin kommen und
wenn man es zum beispiel nehmen wir
der bundesregierung keine gute figur
verhindert in ihrem schlepptau der
schlechteren performen waren oder eine
unberechenbar mal wieder eine warnung
klara geywitz das ist unsere bau
geben es sollte sinnvolle ausweisung von
weiß gar nicht wie man in sylt in ein
nicht gewesen hier zu einer kürzung soll
regierungssprecher deutschlands
dieser traum bestehen weil seine übrigen
wetten seit august aber niemand von den
haben ja mitgekriegt was für enorme
zeit mit ging es um eine
monaten
jetzt mal russland vergleicht haben wir
risch kommt mir die union schon vor
nicht im gegenteil sie stellen alle
für mich war das jetzt ein thema werden
abwehr war dass die spd es geschafft das
wenn du kannst selber sternchen da gibt
durch die mehrmals im deutschlandfunk
kommunikationsberater nummer 1 und
auch nur ganz kurz man muss sich nur
psychologisch interpretiert dass erst
dann wird man sehen ob karl lauterbach
ja ich bin sein 2013 mitglied des
ministerin übrigens auch von spd die hat
verteidigungsministerin ist sondern über
beach ausleben kann gibts dann beach
beträge durch beratungsunternehmen im
auch so ist dass sie sich das heute als
französische präsident sarkozy man
nach dem lauterbach erst vor wenigen
nicht im deutschen bundestag und will
woran liegt das ich habe ehrlich gesagt
ökologische sanierung der häuser mit
jetzt gar nicht so viel weniger ausgaben
immer übergebraten wird klar habe ich
leute die jetzt hier zu ändern wollen im
vergegenwärtigen 2008 war die
neuen gebieten werden damit viel mehr
deutschen bundestags in der zeit haben
was mich ehrlich gesagt in meinem
fielen nach acht stammgast béla anda
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
steiniger das müssen sie schon mit ihrer
die hand nimmt dass er es in die
lernt oder ob er weiterhin in die
junge familie fast gar nicht mehr
tagen prognostizierte dass wir im herbst
wahlkreis von den bürgerinnen und
mir also im nachhinein ist natürlich
ist doch wie so schlecht waren als union
stelle sich vor die ukraine wäre 2008
im gänzlich anderen eindruck wenn sie
scrabble und die sich da dann
house komischer name für sold at kann
wir diesen etat verdoppelt gehabt von
menschen sich diesen traum vom eigenheim
verteidigungsministerium insbesondere
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
es 20 extra punkte weil das hat man noch
leistung zwar trotz niedrigen zinsen
dämmung ja ja klar ja so und wenn man
für militär als beispielsweise andere
jeder weiß doch
etwas dagegen doch tatsächlich dass das
neben der cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete und
konnte ja sie hat der konnte jetzt sechs
bürgern nicht ich mutter darauf nicht
angesprochen fühlen als merkwürdig
partei dazu rechnen lassen denn sie
richtige richtung führt aber nicht
den wunsch der deutschen nach einem
schwarzmeerflotte der russen noch auf
eine klar variante kriegen könnten
jeder jetzt schlauer kopf
also das ist doch mittlerweile
talkshows drängt er lernt nicht ich
ebenfalls freundlich auch nicht so
bei von der leyen abgezockt worden sind
sich anschauen wie wie im bundestag
prozent rentenerhöhung konnte er
eigene heim auch wirklich wahr machen
länder dementsprechend muss man sich
laufend erschreckt und in panik versetzt
allgemeingut oder nicht also wir haben
nie gesehen ehrlich dieses land ist so
daher würde ich mir wünschen dass wir da
noch dass das
aber die baupreise sind massiv
heraus als müssten sie extra bepunktet
er kann man sie ja in ehren halten für
aufgenommen worden es hätte die invasion
eigenheim kritisiert in einem gespräch
gymnasiallehrer johannes steiniger seit
liebevoll zu noch einmal gesagt kultur
glaube dass es in diesem fall haben uns
aufgrund seiner evidenz vereinbarung war
diese grünen roten der darm führen
angesprochen am schluss ist es für mich
der krim damals stationiert und man muss
verkünden konnte aber eigentlich nichts
das nicht versteht damals nicht
diskutiert wird wo auch friedrich merz
haben mit der csu alle
es wäre doch jetzt ist wäre doch jetzt
und jetzt sind die leute gerade ein
hunderte von millionen jedes jahr mit
können so wie es in anderen ländern eben
auch sagen es wurde jetzt einfach mal so
einfach keinen guten wahlkampf geführt
verrückt hier gibt es
werden weil sie sonst nicht schaffen
hochgegangen und deswegen geht man eher
mit dem typischen kartenhaus fall zu tun
zur nächsten bundestagswahl nicht der
kontinuität hätten aber wenn sie in so
dann gerne hat seinen urlaub aber von
anfang des jahres sehr auch mitglied im
die punkte macht sie haben vorhin über
lahm rechts fahren wir zu den sanktionen
verteidigungsminister den letzten jahren
mit der taz als sie gesagt eigenheime
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
ein kunde nicht thema weil es uns davon
bisschen freigelassen worden sie mit
der fall ist denn die eigentumsquote in
weil das sie was besonderes selten das
als bürgerin habe ich mich wirklich
ihm dann nicht nur virologe jonas
verstanden hat das ist doch eigentlich
wir hatten den spitzenkandidaten der
auf kleinere grundstücke aber ich finde
wohl viel zu sagen ja also man hat das
die 100 milliarden gesprochen
sexismus in der linken große debatte und
sich die frage stellen ob dieser
wenn du eine karte herausschießt bricht
fall sein wir sind gespannt denn wenn
cdu bundesvorstand an meiner seite kult
gefragt so gegeben jetzt mal hier 100
russlands auf der krim nicht gegeben es
einer maske mehr tragen überall und da
null ergebnis muss man sagen dass es von
die jahre die sie regiert hat aber das
kommen und da würde ich natürlich gerne
sondervermögen wo wir ganz klar unsere
offensichtlich von den bürgerinnen
konflikt wirklich vermieden hätte werden
ein ding was dem haarberg nicht so fern
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
sind wie der buchstabe q oder y ich
einem riesengroßen haushalt mit mehreren
daher ist er da glaube ich als profi ist
schmidt-chanasit und henrik strikt
schon dass die ministerin hier im grunde
deutschland ist immer noch im
sind im grunde ökonomisch und ökologisch
seit 2005 also können wir die danach
alles zusammen wenn man karl lauterbach
ablenkt uns mit den themen zu
alles schon immer gewusst und 2008 hätte
bürgern nicht gewollt war und dann kommt
kommt karl lauterbach um die ecke wie
draußen betrachtet aber in einem unter
sieht natürlich profitiert hat von der
europäischen vergleich rekord mäßig
herr merz mal auf ne in einer
milliarden los aber muss man nicht erst
punkte gemacht haben in denen wir auch
hundert milliarden euro durch gehen da
gelegen hat die motive für diese
fragen viktor eigentlich ist doch so
panikmache vor was wir in deutschland
unsinnig sagte bundesbau ministerin sagt
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
können oder vielleicht früher
genommen den gesamten ländlichen raum
kolumnist buch autounfälle acht
glaube das ist einfach ein eigentor es
er da profis profi genug die der
hätte auch die soll man sagen das
beschäftigen die wirklich wichtig sind
richten gestellt und die armee ist in
man dann zu einer anderen entscheidung
gender sternchen bei scrabble das steht
mal überlegen ob wir wohl sicher denn
zurückziehen wird als bundeskanzler
agenda 2010 dass die
wenn bei einem die hütte brennt ja da
kann denn der minister der diesen
halt in der demokratie auch mal zum
wahlkampfrede geändert dann wissen wir
solchen bedingungen greifen natürlich
mit ihrer bevölkerung diskreditiert
sicherheit wirtschaft dass die leute was
brauchen ist schluss mit der panikmache
investitionen zu verstehen und heute
finden sie schon in parken auch geld das
ausgebrochen wäre sogar wenn man in den
niedrig also weniger verbote mehr
stammgast hans ulrich jörges sie merken
kommen müssen im nachhinein stimmt das
entstehen in dieser zeit ja auch neue
wechsel was ja grundsätzlich nicht
geld durch was muss man besser machen
kriterien warum wir dann von denen wir
diesem beklagenswerten zustand weil er
restliche spd teil ist tatsächlich
unterwandern der ost ukraine durch
um es nur der dreh zu überlassen lasst
nebeneinander wie sind wir eigentlich
stellt sich die frage warum es
die rüstungskonzerne auch
arbeitsmarktmaßnahmen
damals tatsächlich in meinem freundes
bleibt man ja auch zu hause und fällt
wörter die man noch nie gehört hat mich
schlecht ist wird mir trotzdem derzeit
schluss mit den lauten tönen und
einen plan aufstellt fehlt nicht
haben heute sogar zwei stammgäste das
überhaupt eine andere ministerin das
zu essen in wirklichkeit ist stimmt das
wörtlich es ist ökonomisch und
natürlich das ist was sie gerade eben
dass da nichts verloren dann könnte mit
man sparen können aber erst einige das
ist der jung da war dann war er
arbeitsmarktmaßnahmen nicht sofort
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zum
russische truppen in den vergangenen
lockerungen kein mag keine massen
möglichkeiten das will ich gerne von
gerne lieber eine unionsgeführte
eigentlich frau lambrecht noch
hat's gerissen als ich das erste mal an
den leuten sondern spaß wir sehen da
drauf
abhängig machen dass wir dann auch
und bekanntenkreis so ist da ist der
deswegen mein wunsch karl lauterbach
vielleicht eher der unternehmergeist in
wird sehr lebendig und last but not
nicht ist natürlich ein thema und ich
würde mich interessieren sie sind ja
jahren nicht gegeben ganz zu schweigen
ökologisch unsinnig
bauen von einfamilienhäusern in frage
ausgeführt haben eine argumentation ist
weglaufen gleichwohl ist es so muss man
russen mit einem mit einer nato-mitglied
guttenberg da dann war de maizière da
bundesregierung wünschen der wunsch den
schamlos zu die neben preise die sie
und so war er wog wahnsinn aber das sind
zustimmen und am schluss ist die cdu
kann es denn sein was ist das auch für
pflicht mehr zugestimmt hat gleich im
ministerin unter anderem
gewirkt haben das ist doch jedem klar
finanzfachmann sie sind im
ihren radio nachrichten gehört habe
den grünen fusionieren das glücklos und
wenn jede generation
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
least bildpolitik reporter keine viktor
der bundeswehr als das geld ich glaube
traum dann auch das eigenheim zu haben
soll endlich karl lauterbach werden
natürlich aus meiner sicht auch richtig
stellt dann ja dann legen die axt an die
finanzausschuss hinter ja auch experte
einer engagierten bundesbauministerium
vom jetzigen krieg dann russland hätte
realistisch sehen wir sind derzeit in
ein symbol an die deutsche bevölkerung
will nicht sagen männer wie sie aber es
zivilistinnen und zivilisten
das sind ökonomen klar sie als
dann war frau von der leyen da und dann
kriegen und wenn niemand da ist der sagt
deutschlands eine partei die immer auch
gleichen atemzug sagen aber im herbst
was mir noch wichtig werden neben
politik bei den journalisten deren job
man muss beides machen man muss auf der
wäre die ukraine mitglied der nato hätte
darf man nicht haben mit dem wunsch
nach ein nato staat mit ja als honorar
aus aber ich glaube ich glaube nicht
einfamilienhäuser bauen wenn dann die
wachse hat eine eliteuniversität
kriegszeiten da können jetzt auch nicht
dass frau lambrecht jetzt als
wir haben ja erlebt und das meine ich
sich immer mit der nato angelegt also
gibt natürlich eine gewisse klientel in
doch das habe doch genau die wohlstands
finanzfachmann auch als gymnasiallehrer
cambridge literaturwissenschaft studiert
einen seite das geld zur verfügung
dass friedrich merz anfang wird
das muss man natürlich sorgfältig
zuschüssen heute war es ein bisschen
war frau kramp karrenbauer da und die
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
ein panzer den ihr für 500 millionen
verteidigungsministerin mein urlaub
wird es wieder ganz fürchterlich
alle paar wochen irgendwelche minister
stellen aber dann muss man halt auch
können wir den these dann auch
putin die ukraine eben nicht angegriffen
wurzel einer tragenden branche für
regieren will und deren
jetzt ohne parteipolitische kritik
menschen auf 150 quadratmeter zu beginn
nina dein kunst ist mein wunsch ist
der in der bundespolitik die glaubt
diskussionen der letzten fünf bis zehn
lotterie also die die am anfang da waren
machen müssen es ist ein symbol für
entweder oder dann muss er sich doch
sprechpausen es und nach hoffe ich mal
zu fügen und sie sollen den doch auch
auseinander halten weil zivilistinnen in
und beschäftigt sich jetzt am liebsten
abschließen das ist ihr frommer wunsch
zurücktreten und dann neue rein kommen
dazu kommen dass man das geld effektiv
das hat verheerende wirkungen gehabt und
haben es irgendwie alle nicht
wirklich das aber es verschiedene
wissen das genauso und insofern aber die
unsere wirtschaft da hängen so viele
aber bestimmt nicht also wie gesagt
selbstverständnis es auch ist zu
jahre die jetzt dazu geführt dass wir
da vielleicht geht er dann nicht mehr
herren da ich finde das sehr spannend
verkaufen wollten könnte auch für 250
hingekriegt armee in einen zustand zu
mangelnde lernfähigkeit denn frau
wenn dann müsste es eine erklärung geben
die haben was bekommen danach die nicht
so aber jetzt ist das alles vergossene
richtig dürfte sein
zu fünft leben und dann nach einer zeit
entscheiden ich bin gegen die lockerung
damit sich die mit einer solchen haltung
versuche gegeben hat bei der bundeswehr
dann auch ausgibt und sie wissen wir
wir werden sehen wie es weitergeht in
mit der deutschen politik quasi von
mittelständler dran handwerker die im
regieren und von daher sollte es dazu
mehr eigentlich auch er wäre mir noch
hinterher sind wie vielfach schlauer ich
heute tatsächlich und gemeint aber
der ukraine gehen ja eher ins ausland um
dem kunden überhaupt nicht mehr rasieren
als sex ist das war er doch mal vorwürfe
frage was auf die freundliche höfliche
haben das beschaffungsamt in koblenz da
wollte dann wenn der bundeskanzler ihren
lambrecht ist teil der ampelkoalition
millionen verkaufen wenn das gezahlt
was die gesagt habe es klingt fast so
den nächsten jahren und wenn deutschland
ich frage mich wann eigentlich frau
der masten pflicht gegen die aufgabe
milch was mir viel wichtiger wäre wäre
versetzen einheit noch die wehrpflicht
dass lambrecht zurücktreten soll bitte
gehen die kinder aus dem haus das haus
oder die erweiterung sind aber noch mal
manko leicht einmal kurz einsatz
diesen milliarden flüssen irgendwie auf
eine koalition stehen wir natürlich
shakespeare zu politics falls sie heute
und hat gerade schmerz verliebt wie eine
antwort ich habe eine wand stand
liberal konservativ für mich und nicht
führt und damit kommen wir zur letzten
wichtig dass der staat ein bisschen
glaube nicht dass das funktioniert hätte
sich in sicherheit zu bringen mit den
ich kenne nicht die zustimmung des
sind sag ich mal die wege durchaus
dagegen setzte es aber nicht durch dann
hausbau und im wohnungsbau tätig sind
abgeschafft dass sie jetzt verteidigungs
wird machen dies auch und deshalb
in der hinsicht vielleicht ist das
die frage was lernen wir eigentlich nach
wirklich nur nur zustimmen denn was karl
merkel mal dazu stellung nehmen will zu
zurückzieht stellt sich sofort die frage
sie haben doch gesagt dass lambrecht so
deutschland basiert der seite machen wir
aber da ich glaube und labs als
zurück steckt also bei diesen hohen
zurückzukommen auf auf das thema was
kindern die zivilisten wiederum werden
these für heute abend und das ist deine
das erste mal einschalten jeder von uns
gender ganz gut um sich neu zu erfinden
ministerin in ihrem eigenen kabinett
nach spd immer älter und
versichern da so ungeheure beträge ohne
schrumpft und in dem moment aber nicht
ich habe nicht gesagt dass lamprecht
stammtisches zu holen aber stammt das
doch das sind übliche anorak träger aus
bürokratische monster und machen aber
warum es vor lampe ministerin wenn du
vorne raus weil das was jetzt mit
fähig ist und da muss man sagen da
die spur zu kommen ursula von der leyen
muss er dafür antreten dann muss sagen
ihrer eigenen position
meinerseits man kann daraus lernen dass
preisen kassiert der staat ja immer dann
zurücktreten soll sondern das völlig
architektenbüros und so weiter das wird
für herr merz also erstens ist friedrich
viktor
mich am meisten ärgert ist sozusagen
haben die hinterräder nach jeder merken
zurücktreten musste wegen eines urlaubs
hat ein tagesaktuelles thema mitgebracht
zwar mehr einberufen so wird das aber
deplatziert ist und ich fand frau
die haben wir haben gesamtetat leder
ehrlich gesagt auch nur die machen aber
dass man den effekt merk wir werden es
von abends dann meine these ist dass
sie ist abgetaucht sie ist aber keine
hat das wird die intensiv versucht indem
auch ihre getroffen
dieses bevormundende was da drin ich hab
sollten wir auch nicht ganz ausklammern
einen gehen lässt
ich stehe mit dem gesetzentwurf des fdp
lauterbach am sonntag im bild am sonntag
so zitat ende sagt sie gegenüber der taz
russland passiert gebe ich im brief und
wo der mangel an die schäden nicht über
ersehen bewegt oder berührt das kann ein
ist also eine gewisse die idee der
mit ab wenn er beispielsweise
nicht dargestellt sondern das sind
unklare verhältnisse für einen staat
in einer krise und was macht sie eine
ehrlich gesagt auch nur das was wir ihn
mal eben so in einem interview erklärt
merz kein sex ist und zweitens ist eine
vor dem hintergrund dessen dass wir hier
lambrecht von anfang an als ministerin
ich habe meinen vater meine sache immer
grunderwerbsteuer einnimmt ich wäre sehr
heute nicht mehr lösen können das
sie als kind sehr eingebracht am ende
ministers nicht zu aus diesem grund weil
die bilanz von schröder und merkel der
mir das heute auf der homepage schon
müssen andere mitgehen und dann hat es
siegel ist in den nächsten fünf bis zehn
immerhin also abgeliefert hat das war
zivilistinnen und zivilisten die vor dem
bevölkerung ist der normalen kitchen
woche später widerstand richtig sagt sie
statement aus der politik sein schrieb
das haus schrumpft nicht das ist zwar
gender sternchen beim scrabble spielen
als politik vorgeschrieben haben sprich
also ich glaube da ist jetzt der zeit
problem der bundeswehr auch wenn wir uns
also wenn man ihnen eine grauzone stößt
angeschaut also da steht irgendwie so
jeder so leben können wie er das klingt
verschiedene andere themen
weil man der meinung ist dass das die
rede über die frage wer barcelona
dafür wenn wir da mal im
anbiederung auch immer das schlechteste
privatperson geworden sie hat ein büro
ist das auch schief gelaufen aber sie
bekommt er kümmert sich darum niemand
gleich eine richtige fettere ja dieser
im herbst kommt ein ganz schrecklicher
nicht wirklich an geeigneter position
redlich bemühen und kommen jetzt so
jahren eine frage auch im verhältnis zu
mitdiskutieren
table politics also im grunde diejenigen
er später in meinem fall oder ein
sinngemäß tja man möchte die menschen
jetzt nicht unbedingt die zeit einer
glaube ich etwas wo er mit einer
gesellschaftlichen kraftakt machen und
fährt in urlaub wie blöd kann man eins
krieg fliehen ins ausland das ist leider
hat zumindest versuch und und trotzdem
im panzer muss auch die neun monate
tatsächlich dafür schrumpft offenbar die
sie alle kennen das spiel scrabble man
leute sollen anders leben und wenn mir
was man machen kann man muss in der
das war die ukraine wo man nicht wusste
geholfen hat und wer für ihn nützlicher
mit neuen angestellten mehr als jeder
virus aber nicht dem zustimmen und dann
zeit bleibt da auch noch an der spiegel
für mich eher nach der fdp aber sehen
zeitungsartikel es geht hier die
ich glaube ich schon also ich nehme die
china und da haben wir doch genau die
deiner t soja und seitdem angebrannt wir
die wir heuer werden und immer wichtiger
gestellt ich kenne sie noch als
schlagzeile gerechnet hat es wurde zwar
sagen bei der ersten immobilie keine
selbstbeschäftigung in einer enquete
sein also ich hab gedacht wo ist der
auch daran gewöhnen und hin führen dass
falsch in der sache weil die zivilisten
politik authentisch sein und von daher
will den mann ist ja ganz knapp drüber
bereitschaft menschen so leben zu lassen
war hier hat schröder war nach dem ende
wozu gehört die überhaupt gehört die zur
leute kommen die mir erklären wie ich
wir auch ja ich bin ja nicht hier für
ist doch ein urlaub gefahren dann ist
legt wörter aus steinchen mit buchstaben
schwangere frau die als soldatin und
hat man das gefühl gibt es milliarden
gedankliche freiheit und jetzt wollen
lerneffekt überhaupt nicht da waren sind
hinterher damit er wieder mal
kommission die am schluss vielleicht
andere kanzler vor ihr also ein
ist ja nicht dürfen aber wie kann man
grunderwerbsteuer ja wenn ich das
eine andere dann aber ich habe es
sind natürlich von den normalen themen
sie gegangen aber frau ist immer noch
leben sollen werde ich sowieso sauer
staatssekretär im finanzministerium da
oder sehen etwas erwerben zu lassen was
reden viel über die spd die spd hat wie
ruhe zu europa zum besten oder ist sie
gleichen themen nord stream 2 von
eine partei sich hier ich werde anders
seiner kanzlerschaft 2005 nicht mehr als
sowieso nichts zu entscheiden hat ich
man das sozusagen auch immer in seinen
kritik verteidigen sie nicht so was
und jetzt hat der hersteller von
wir auch direkt loslegen mit dem thema
die reingesteckt werden in die
und dann auch noch mit bärbel bas der
weil ich entscheide selber gerne wie ich
das ging die sache dass nach dem
abgeordneter kommt werde eigentlich eher
war es ehrlich gesagt ähnlich im
überhaupt einen solchen begriff zivilist
also ich kann mit den sprach pausen beim
und jenseits berlin-mitte nichts mit dem
nach wie vor auf moskau orientiert die
alle gemerkt haben dass putin problem
griller du hast gesagt hat den schuss
sprechen das ist ein fakt nicht fertig
russland ist die seitenstraße der
arbeitsfähige behörde klein behörde
als bei ihnen aber
richtig sehe kaum frau wird aus potsdam
nicht zu verteidigen ist
auftritt ging es nicht anders ist ja
spd bundespräsidenten also dümmer geht's
sie wollen eben ein eigenheim sich den
ausstich teil deutlich können sie eine
bundeswehr die aber trotzdem
normalen sprachbild nimmt und an manchen
einfach so medien versessen dass er
finde dass wir wenn wir ein strich
von herrscht einiger hersteller legen
lebe das wird auch so bleiben das werden
innen erfinden mit aktivistinnen und
ost ukraine richtung moskau in die
scrabble nämlich mattel gesagt also wir
gebaren hier zu tun haben nur das wird
was so etwas wenn diese krise ein gutes
insofern bin ich ein kleid ist hier für
sage nur die spd und antworte ich glaube
nicht gehört er schießt ja laufend
ist das richtig wie kann man in
cenelec nichts anfangen ja das ist auch
chinesen
ineffizient gebraucht werden verbraucht
sozusagen die auch meine rede
glaubt ich muss jeweils bieten deswegen
oder so ist heute mir es würde mir fern
auch selber zurückgetreten ja von ihrer
nicht weder dümmer geht es nicht sagte
universitäten kriegt man ja quasi was
drunter machen den letzten zwei jahren
andere hälfte war richtung europa
anekdote mit uns teilen
richtig wo ist die aufgabe von
machen das kleine gender sternchen da
los ja ich kann nicht verstehen wie man
selbst zu erschließen darauf wird er
auch die menschen zu durchsetzen ja
energiekonzerne er saß bei bader gazprom
einfluss überall auf der welt und von
zivilisten habe ich überhaupt keine
gut durch diese corona krise
die wild angenommen jeder so leben wie
rede ich mal von der kieler variante das
traum vom eigenheim erfüllen zu können
sich radikal ändern weil auch am kitchen
journalismus einfach die verlautbarungen
nicht besonders ästhetisch gut ich
aufschreiben kann oder ein interview
orientiert und sie gehörte weder zur eu
dazu sternchen ii entsteht ist überall
hat dann ist es hoffentlich dass wir da
abgezogen wenn man nicht geändert
albrecht im finanzausschuss dass das
brandenburg in einer großstadt wie
werden braucht es nicht eine stärkere
partei zurück getreten worden sagen wir
liegen großen teil als nicht zu
durchgekommen sind sowohl wirtschaftlich
victor du als kommunikationsberater
probleme ich scheue mich was noch
völlig zurecht und und und wir wollen ja
auch die cdu und zwar in gestalt ihrer
funktioniert bei bild bitte am sonntag
will auf sich aufmerksam machen und das
als verteidigungsministerin in diesen
daher würde ich mir wünschen dass sich
glaube wir werden nicht anfangen bei
stattdessen hören wird nur boote dass
table am küchentisch sitzen junge frauen
organisieren kann und sie selbst und
er will ist er ursprungs kommunismus so
mal so hoch sein aber die spd tritt doch
dabei man bekommt man soll nicht nur
weiter bei den pipeline
menschelt sternchen arbeit was oder
sind ja nicht öffentlicher sitzung aber
verteidigen ist erinnere mich noch gut
noch zur nato und das ist 2008 an
vielen ländern wir sind jetzt auch schon
kriegszeiten auf die idee kommen kann in
die deutsche politik in ihrer und auch
hättest du ihr geraten ins peaches nach
berlin berlin mitte eine solche meinung
sehr gut und dann haben die die
aber auch bei den krankheits und
aufsicht finanziell finanzaufsicht über
akustisch einfach immer ein bisschen so
war wieder mal so ein zitat von dem er
tochtergesellschaften und bei rosneft in
irgendwas nicht sein da weil es nicht
kanzler königin angela merkel gebe die
an den cdu-bundesparteitag es war mein
wenn sie sich sozusagen entlang hangeln
niemanden zurück wenn dann müssten sie
licht aus diesen satz schreiben waren
die so einfordert werden und das
sondern man bekommt auch noch fett
aber genau daran hat mich der immer
einem gemeinsamen spirit um zu überlegen
nicht drangsaliert werden in einem in
schlagzeile und ich bin wieder da auf
vertreten ist mir rätselhaft und ich
die wirtschaft im übrigen in ihrem
genau wusste was ich auslöse
den urlaub zu fahren während die ukraine
am ende der sendung angekommen ich
todesfällen es hat vieles aufgedeckt was
ökologisch richtig ist oder ökonomisch
zwar diese neuen leute bezahlt vom
alle zurücktreten fast ausnahmslos aus
extra-punkte wenn man geändert nämlich
sie also also also wahnsinn dass man
gerichte politik verzeiht dahin macht
müssen an ihrem sprechzettel dann wird
leiser frage herr anders ich bin
berührt dass sind diese zivilistinnen
erster als uns zu guttenberg erklärte
verhältnis zu china jetzt mal erlebt was
die entsprechenden ausschüsse dass man
den aufsichtsorganen aber er hatte ja
weil ich mal so viele politiker haben
einem öko und ökologischen
den titelseiten und kommen in die
das ist unverantwortlich ehrlich gesagt
glaube sie wird sich in brandenburg
kanzlerin die für putin nützlicher war
steuerzahler und sie selbst legt 15.000
wir noch verbessern müssen insbesondere
es halt immer schon schwierig und man
uns ja anflehen dass wir ihnen schwere
gegenlager in einer villa dann bin ich
was man dem geld anfängt das gibt's ja
zehn mehr das kriegt man sonst nur wenn
möchte mich ganz herzlich bei meinen
ist so schrecklich weil in einem solchen
sozusagen für eine laut duden korrekte
sagt wir kontrollieren wirklich mal
nächste runde der talkshows wo ich ja
damit auch nicht besonders beliebt
vernünftig oder unsinnig sogar
natürlich ganz bei ihnen inhalt ich
im gesundheitsbereich aber ich habe da
wobei deshalb der meinung bin ich auch
wenn jemand dann innehält und diese
keine keine politischen
erkennt dass der kommunikationsprofi
warum wir jetzt die wehrpflicht
ärger mit ihren urlauben gehabt jeder
auch fragen und ich bin ja wohl gar
euro pension ungefähr im monat das ist
machen ja ich freue mich dass auch warum
gästen bedanken und bei béla anda war
können wir denn da so machen dass wir
so ein minister nicht mehr tragbar aber
genau wie die durchflüsse und abflüsse
nich bisher dieses gemeinsamer runde der
immer unbedingt hinwill ich hätte mir
glaube sie haben völlig recht so eine
alle zurücktreten dir nicht im kabinett
man eine besonderheit schafft nämlich
korsett nur leben dürfen das so weit
abschaffen aller standen und alle
waffen liefern war sie im beach house
tatsächlich ist aber der eigenheim
eingriffsmöglichkeit er war nicht mehr
wenn dann jemand tatsächlich nicht so
kunst pause macht um beide geschlechter
schreibweise etwas abgezogen bekommt
art platz pro person per se pauschal
nicht zum ersten mal hier verunglimpft
weiß doch was da auf einen zukommt es
wie oft haben wir schon gesagt er macht
nicht in zehn jahren in der situation
eine gewisse verpflichtung sie steht
dass den buchstaben y oder kuh zu
der bundestagsparteien wo sie sich
nicht gedacht dass es so bleibt ist ich
und das heißt als letzte frage wie
auch militärisch und das ist passiert
sind tatsächlich sage ich jetzt mal als
genannten auf den tischen und haben im
steiniger bei uli und natürlich auch bei
kanzler während angela merkel kanzlerin
sylt unterwegs wie ich gelesen habe und
einzubringen das hat sich mir noch nicht
schon mal vor zwei wochen hier an der
wunsch der hier diskreditiert wird ein
hier kriegt man in einem spiel was sich
sind wir alle wieder sagen ach hätten
viel gescholtene gerhard schröder sie
es ja immer wieder aber unverantwortlich
ist ein erkenntnis auch ich meine der
zusammensetzen und gemeinsam besprechen
glaube tatsächlich dass so ein bisschen
und ich will ja nicht der angela merkel
geht dass uns die form der häuser die
zuge yoga so dass man sich auch noch an
erinnern kann stammtisch ich habe nie
viel ahnung von der materie hat oder
nach wie vor im öffentlichen leben ich
stelle gesagt wenn ich die vier monate
bundestagsabgeordneter genau das
bin mittlerweile davon überzeugt ich bin
würdest du deine als erstes schmeißen
festzulegen den es in deutschland gibt
ist ja aus meiner sicht auch dass er ja
lauterbach syndrom ist sie haben jetzt
war und mit ihrer mit ihren politischen
verwenden ich finde aber frauen und 9
hat nämlich
wir nicht vor zehn jahren in anderen
wunsch von vielen tausend wenn ich gern
ist nicht nur eine regierungs aufgabe da
wenn jemand sozusagen nur als
so ganz vermitteln aber ich meine wir
das ist aus meiner sicht sehr sehr
gegenteil also ich beschneide jetzt
ja eigentlich der rechtschreibung
soviel platz kann eine person haben und
überlegens bescheuert und man kriegt ja
wir anstreben hat sich auch madig
wenn du erst heute könntest ja ich meine
viktor und ich möchte jetzt einmal die
erwarte von angela merkel mal eine
auch dem anliegen einen bärendienst
von karl lauterbach vergleiche mit den
die ganze zeit nicht vor die 400.000
stand friedrich merz damit ich höre ihn
daran gesetzt werden die da sitzen ist
nur mittlerweile müsste er doch den
gedächtnisstütze nimmt ich stehe mit
unsensibel und auch instinktlos es ist
verschrieben hat für eine grundfalsche
entgegen halten ja ich habe auch nicht
binäre menschen sind keine besonderheit
müssen wir uns dann auch selbst kenne
zunächst mal die die ukraine
dass jahns grundgesetz gehen soll und
eigentlich meine eigene kompetenz es ist
millionen von menschen wir haben sie in
der regen überall wurde immer lauter
fähigkeiten in die weltpolitik
haben sonst pause ist dafür da dass die
ich minister oder ministerin in
erweist weil erstens will keiner mehr
zeit auch nutzen sie auf unseren
zwei jahren zwei jahren von jens spahn
ihrem eindruck zu der spd teil des
mehr nicht das klingt für mich nach
wohnungen die sie sich vorgenommen haben
nicht ich sehe nicht mit genau dieser
ich natürlich überlegen in was für einer
schuss gehört haben es müssen auch
die brauchen keine bevormundung und sie
das ja nein das ist kein
der korona pandemie gesehen der wohnt
gemacht wird denn ich bleib dabei dieser
schreibweise extra punkte während ich
auch das grundgesetz verändert werden
gedacht dass putin den fehler macht
newsletter hinzuweisen die haben nämlich
eingegriffen hat um putin zu helfen
also so investitionen in der bundeswehr
erklärung und einen akt der selbstkritik
nordkorea oder nach sowjetunion ist
hören zweitens genau das also heute
nicht so dass ich jetzt denken würde
nordrhein will aus nordrhein westfalen
aussage ständiger friedrich merz schon
hat sich entspannt ich ziemlich gut
lauter machen sich im moment abgesehen
im koalitionsvertrag kriegt sie im leben
kabinetts ist erbärmlich die grünen
zeit war ist gleichzeitig will ich
geschleppten ja nicht männer und frauen
vernünftige leute geben eine
müssen nicht herausgestellt werden das
muss mit einer zweidrittelmehrheit
finde ich einen solchen krieg
als bundestagsabgeordneter sie sind doch
dass so eine verteidigungsministerin
gemacht aber der termin
jeden montag einen newsletter der um
natürlich völliger quatsch und meine
traum vom eigenheim so schwerer ist
stehen in diesem jahr aber sie wollte
sich nach einem eigenen kleinen häuschen
auf mallorca urlaub während die menschen
natürlich schon eins sagen am schluss
ab 25 millionen euro müssen durch den
bundesregierung bei ihm auch im
einmal in der hinsicht dass sie die die
müssen die mindestens die union noch
also ich würde mir tatsächlich auch
anzuzetteln aber soll sie doch mal uns
masten pflicht weg morgen kommt die
seit vier jahren seit er öffentlich
schafft er das gegenteil das hilft ihm
wieder vehement dagegen und ich glaube
kein urlaub verdient hätte oder dass sie
sind dafür ist die kunst
von seiner rhetorik nicht mehr gefragt
antwort auf ihre these ist auch ganz
sicher auch schon mal leidenschaftlich
vielleicht mit garten irgendwo ist
in deraa ertranken also auch da gab es
machen die beste figur die fdp macht
haushaltsausschuss so das führt dazu
20.15 verschickt wird und da können sie
um geschädigt dadurch dass sie bei der
jetzt irgendwie glaube ich nochmal
geht es natürlich auch nur mit geld und
ministerium nach dem guten
bleibt ein traum für viele viele
noch mal rein absolut hier zu wenig
killer variante die leute denken sich ja
wünschen dass wir mal etwas von angela
daran beteiligt werden und das kann man
überhaupt nicht die sind mündig die
weil die weil die leute sind ja relativ
mal erklären wie sie damals die
emotional denn während corona konnten
kommunikationsprofi hier gesagt dass man
nord stream 2 durchgesetzt hat wie sie
vorkommen und mit ein bisschen eigenheim
wieder auftritt sie können sich seine
vielleicht nicht das was sie in
geworden am rednerpult von bildern aus
ist es klingt es ein bisschen
dass jede größere investition 25
können auf sich selbst aufpassen und ich
menschen und ich möchte mir nicht sagen
gab es natürlich entsprechende vorgänge
wenn ich mir anschaue wie wird die
situation eingeschätzt hat warum sie so
eine ganz gute figur frau stark
es gerne für anmelden es gibt immer eine
schon erwarten aber das ist ja nichts
berlin-mitte vorrang hat aber in
auch nicht dass das so kommen wird die
in der kaserne die munitionskisten
merkel zu der gesamten geschichte hören
habt ihr noch alle in der
reden anschauen war einer der ersten
bashing läuft man eigentlich dann auch
entspannt die gegen die urlaubszeit
diskussion über zwei prozent ziel in den
glaube dass ihnen die firma mattel hier
passiert also es gibt ein beschluss für
meine brüder und meine ganze familie die
sendezeit hier übrig gelassen die letzte
ambitioniert oder durch angrillen aber
ausgeteilt ausgerastet gegen die anderen
aufgabe bisschen weniger talkshow
wegen des ukraine kriegs gestopft werden
lassen von welchem verantwortlichen
bundesregierung von da erweist dem einen
die zu kritisieren sind und wir hätten
bau der beim bau der
ländlichen gebieten rheinland pfalz in
meinung oder eine these die sie
entschieden hat gegen george bush den
zimmermann ist diejenige die sozusagen
millionen im rüstungsbereich ist dann
ich habe noch nie im privaten
deutschen politiker die das thema china
gefragt ist jetzt eine effiziente
immer mehr die aber die spd ist die
letzten jahren geführt hatten dann war
man muss aber glaube ich schon
die beschaffung eines neuen
eher einen bärendienst erweist und ich
wir alle hier in berlin oder in anderen
bisschen mehr ministerium da gibt es
musste und zweitens weil sie die
packen soll aber ich glaube gerade in
parteien und ich habe eine rede gesehen
nord-stream-pipeline 2
jagdflugzeugs und das war es erstmal
partei der normalen leute in dem sinne
nordrhein-westfalen in hoyerswerda in
politiker oder von welcher
zusammenhang gehört dass eine junge frau
feststellen es gibt schon noch mal ein
die union die einzige partei die das 210
hoffentlich genauso gut finden oder
städten ganz kleinen wohnungen wohnen
da die die die class die figur ist im
frage die ich nämlich noch habe zu
wünschen der mit tollen
überhaupt wieder angesprochen haben und
ich meine da sie haben doch in cambridge
sie sich ja auch gedacht getan hast
bärendienst das wahrscheinlich die
muss sozusagen es immer jeweils für den
glaube dass dieser wahnsinn ein ende
diesen zeiten ist es absolut falsche
verantwortlichen politikerinnen auch
besetzung des verteidigungsministeriums
unterschied zwischen gerhard schröder
alle nur an einen ort immer gehen und
meiner these und karl lauterbach gibt es
von müller fest wenn sie das ist eine
sehr viel zu tun so kann man das haben
in ihrem selbstverständnis schon lange
geändert hätte beim reden noch nicht
vorbei so schlimm es tatsächlich ehrlich
menschen auch nicht mehr ernst nehmen
berchtesgaden in cloppenburg und vechta
schlussviertel der these jetzt folgt
einiger aber
nicht gut finden wie wir und
zunächst mal die europäischen
aufnahme der ukraine die nato verhindert
haben muss wo waren sie ein ende haben
signal zum einen unsere bevölkerung es
immer wieder auch gefordert hat und wir
aber offensichtlich haben sich von den
wir doch in der korona pandemie gesehen
ob das mann oder frau ist interessiert
immer wie ich mein leben dann zu
studiert man das ist doch england ist
werden und mir kommt es so ein bisschen
das war das haus meiner großeltern das
bereich von verteidigung auf eine
ausschuss aufbereitet werden kommt dann
und angela merkel gerhard schröder ist
grünzone ich habe es die jüngste
denn irgendeine chance da selbst
dementsprechend das war es auch mit der
sonst wo überhaupt und dieser traum vom
einmal weil das doch mängel fest das
insofern jeder weiß auch wenn als
widerstände bei seite geräumt hat und im
meine und es geht um unseren beiden
ganz schön entfernen weil wenn ein paar
vor wie so ein adhs kind was immer dann
natürlich in der problematik waren dass
hat das waren einschneidende
mich nicht frau stark zimmermann werden
gesagt nicht weil also intern verhandeln
genehme fläche gestellt ohne dass ich
ist groß obwohl sie dann noch zu zweit
sich dieser staat entwickelt er
gestalten hartes du hast völlig recht
kommt so ein bisschen rüber als ob das
erst in der sitzung wird dann da
die digitalisierung kommt nicht voran
abgeordnete die
wird durch stimmen die der 100-prozentig
werbung bis morgen abend schütz haben
entscheidung sollte solche
auf der payroll von putin lobby irrt
doch das große land der liberalität an
vortragende figur baute die frau stark
sommer vergangenen jahres auch noch die
sind und das wäre nicht gegangen
zurücktreten muss überhaupt also wenn er
lieblings freund karl lauterbach meine
mehr kollegen ihre bürgersprechstunde
alles gar nicht so schlimm sei obwohl
trinken bitte emilia fester die grünen
es insbesondere bei der spd aber früher
politiker in so einer phase nach sylt
entsprechend formell auch durch
wenn es mal keine aufmerksamkeit
zu und das schlimmste ist für mich immer
wir als größte oppositionsfraktion
eigenheim ist aber in den letzten jahren
einschneidenden entscheidungen zugunsten
natürlich auch aus seiner
rede jetzt vom ukraine krieg ich meine
sie noch einen schönen abend
die die gehälter für die pflegekräfte
und in dieser gesellschaft ist es ja
insofern stimmt mich jedenfalls es ist
diskutiert das heißt uns wird auch sage
ordentlich machen würden dann würden die
irgendwann irgendwas macht die das alle
amerikanischen sanktionspläne
wirtschaftlichen expertise heraus sich
zwei flugstunden entfernt immer noch
koalition lang große zusteller sind die
wert dass er sich an reinhold bei sylt
diesen universitäten ist man doch ein
freundinnen
natürlich derzeit mit der ampel ich höre
von putin hat schröder nie getroffen
zimmermann wären es hervorragende figur
wirklich in einer fast unverschämten art
sich so weiter fällt und mich jeden tag
ja es liegt da ist sie die eindeutig auf
hast und ich kann ja sein dass die
viel schwerer geworden zu realisieren
ich wurde letztens auch wieder
zerschlagen hat damit war klar wenn
these heute abend ist nämlich dass karl
auch in der pandemie deutlich an die
übrigens das zweite mal schon dass diese
ist vielen pflegekräfte es gibt so viel
auch ganz genau anschaut was sie denn
wahnsinnig mal auf twitter wegen der
bundeswehr einen privaten zusammenhang
ich mal aus dem apparat selbst
eingeladen als gestern das habe ich dann
hier gar nicht wie man da wieder rennt
krieg herrscht aber noch viel schlimmer
leute durch werden wo die union die wahl
konnte er gar nicht er war aus dem
panzer der bundeswehr als sparbüchse
kinder denken niemand und ist es
aus den gesprächen dass das ja etwas
niedrige zinsen hin oder her weil dies
absoluter freigeist
und weise in den vergangenen jahren für
zulässig dass leute anderer meinung sind
zurückgespiegelt das natürlich diese
lauterbach solche karl lauterbach werken
als urlaubs insel der reichen und der
neuen variante sehe keinen grund warum
wie man den eindruck den man hat
regierung oder aus dieser regierung mit
aber vielleicht findet sich auch jemand
sagt sie ist wie putin der sagt auch
benutzt worden ja dass man sich immer
noch keine junge frau gesehen oder auch
nicht der krieg gekommen wäre die
ist ein ganz schlechtes zeichen in
geschäft stimmt aber der ukrainische
gewonnen muss ich hier leider wir sagen
als ich und das halte ich für zulässig
zu tun in diesem haus ich mir wünsche
und ich dachte man die arme da ist sie
direkt abgelehnt diese einladungen per
ausdrücken soll ohne dass es justiziabel
man zurücktreten was auch wenn die
natürlich ein wichtiges motiv von
dinge auch dafür sorgen dass anschluss
schönen gilt es gibt ja auch andere
warum dann so verengt und so spießig
pipeline wird zu ende gebaut deutschland
dieses thema ist ja jetzt dann über
ruckelt weil nämlich die anschuldigen je
dem bauen gespielt wird leichtfertig aus
noch immens teuer geworden ist und die
eine ältere überhaupt eine frau die geht
botschafter namik hat mir mal 2009/10
richtung der ukraine bator man müsse
mehr still gelegt worden da sind ja
bürger sich wünschen
und insofern für mich im moment die
und wie komme ich darauf
menschen ein einfamilienhaus zu bauen
mail weil ich keine gäste in bin ich bin
ist ein teil der zeit den aufwendet in
genau das was er machen will und diese
ecken das wissen wir auch alles aber was
sage ich mal eben nicht so schnell
wird also ich sage mal hin vorsichtige
ja auch keinen an den übrigen das spielt
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
oder europa werden noch abhängiger
istanbul nach moskau geflogen und wollte
100 milliarden gar nicht nur für die
so in rage und das ganze riecht
nein so nicht aber natürlich wenn er
oder ein reihenhäuschen zu nehmen wegen
höchstens noch die hälfte der heutigen
jetzigen ökonom geschnittene
schon gesagt hat sich nach dem bundestag
an denen ich habe schon mal gedacht aber
kurzsichtigen erwägungen der erste war
darüber nachdenken sanktionen gegen
sekunden ein mensch ist doch toll
lauterbach ist ja eine der stimmen der
aufgrund des haushaltsrechts agiert
form die ich finden kann der hat nicht
gewesen von russischem gas punkt 1.2
ein gast und früher in der schule wenn
bundeswehr ausgeben will sondern da
gearbeitet habe er hat so angst dass sie
und die chinesen sagen dass im grunde
entscheidende frage der ukraine kriegt
panzer vor allen dingen statt bargeld
ökologischen anforderungen machen es
kommt immer es das wissen wir aus
talkshows panik zu verbreiten
im normalen leben gar keine rolle und es
kindern weil kinder sich dort im kleinen
irgendwie so ein schluck wasser in der
sich mal informieren
sprache verändert sich wenn menschen das
deutschland zu verhängen sanktionen
regierung ja auch nach zweieinhalb
werden kann mein thema ist wir sind in
mehr alle am sträußchen könnte das
vielleicht auch noch ein paar andere
da ist frau stark zimmermann schon die
kurve auseinander weil sie ihnen sagen
genommen die letzten 200 jahren fehler
übrigen nutzbar naja schwarz warum hat
wird weiterhin keine rolle spielen
völlig das vertrauen der ministerin
aufwendet für die zeit in seinem haus es
ideen hat wo es geld unterkommen soll
klang erlebnis wird er dann zum friseur
geht denn in dem jahr an dass in dem sie
verschiedenen anderen urlauben und es
gegen deutschland nicht in russland weil
jahren drohen ab anime und nach all den
nochmal teurer es müssen der heizung
herr habeck der die die kfw mittel für
garten bewegen können oder auch mal auf
der lehrer gerufen hat alle schüler
richtige ich wollte aber eigentlich
sondern es spielt eine rolle für
innovia sie tradition mit der killer
der geschichte waren weil man keine
annehmen und tun wir schreiben ja auch
am schluss soll ist die emi die kollegin
sagen dass diese regierung ist an den
und uns ist eben wichtig die 100
der
gehen jetzt raus vorjahr da stand ich
gibt immer eine skandalisierung auch
minister des bundeskanzlers verliert
der straße spielen können während in
so einer existenziellen krise und ich
ihr amt verlässt wird er angreifen und
neuen erkenntnissen immer noch nach
ist weniger werden wo ist da gibt es
wer hat uns denn das bessere deutschland
weltmacht mir bei ihm bleiben noch
eben deutschland nicht in die schule
variante zu kommen zeugt nicht von
ausgetauscht werden wärmepumpen
und insofern
bestimmte viertel in der politik die
milliarden euro sollen komplett für die
nicht mehr in sütterlin dann kann man
einmal bei der these von jörges dass
einer wohnung in einer großstadt kinder
ich weiß es frauen mehr merken jetzt
frühere polnische eu ratspräsident
harten maßnahmen was heißt eine der
auch weniger schlacht sein aber das
genau das ist passiert das kann ich
fester soll soll reden wie sie will
komme in diesem konflikt weil
eine verteidigungsministerium hat man
ökologisches bauen über nacht gebrechen
integriert werden die dämmungen neu
nicht daran hab gesagt moment ich bin
hinterlassen weil sie haben ja gerade
wenn er die bevölkerung in erregung
streitkräfte ausgegeben werden wir
also man muss da schon selbst können sie
schon an den sollbruchstellen angekommen
eine kurze unterbrechungen sind dann
kapiert in was für einer existenziellen
nicht zustimmen wie gesagt auch mal ein
eine schülerin ich bin nicht
glauben damit ihrer modernität beweisen
auch sagen ich spiele muss eine solche
hilft vielleicht der bevölkerung und
schlecht aufgehoben sind das ist ein
urlaub verdient das ist richtig nur es
sollte es in ihrem privatbereich machen
es gab doch den den den griechischen
merkel putin mehr genutzt hat als
gerhard schröder angesprochen also dem
deutschland nicht bereit sei die
brauchen bessere beschaffungen das was
stimmen eigentlich versteht sich niemand
gemacht wird alles wird teurer und dann
angesprochen ich bleibe hier sitzen wir
zurück mit dem thema von béla anda bis
sind ja auch bereit dazu wie man merkt
krise wir sind dass wir einfach ganz
hat da ist fast die ganze branche
auch den pflegekräften mehr als nur
also eine koalition zwischen dieser spd
energieimporte aus russland zu beenden
neue
zu müssen und es spielt eine rolle in
wesentliches motiv für den bau von
argument dagegen was man in der beim
versetzt ohne lösungen zu bieten wenn er
donald tusk hat das als ihren größten
gibt einfach das falsche signal es kann
im zweifel auch weil es ihr so in
der feuerprobe ich finde ländern ist
schröder und es wurde auch gerade gesagt
sie gerade eben genannt haben und von
so sehr auf die panikmache wie er keiner
zusammengebrochen niemand wusste was
sollten wir den vorwurf machen wann
das muss man selbst kritisch betrachten
kommunikation
viel neu denken müssen und dazu gehört
finanzminister der uns allen aufrufen
nato-gipfel in bukarest
gleich also da kann ich ein lauter
eigenen häusern und es kommt dazu dass
fehler bezeichnet die förderung der
wird uns auch noch mit diesem argument
wie hier an dieser stelle natürlich
dass merkel ist abgetaucht ist oder
fleisch und blut übergegangen ist am
heute nachdem der kriege in der ukraine
panik zu verbreiten und die menschen im
daher sind hier immer zugeschlagen er
und weil deutschland den alten stiefel
und in meinen anderen parteien wird
stand deutschland denn besser da nach
anti feministische weil man immer
kann es so gut und vor knapp zwei
ist
davon niemand es konsultiert worden das
feministischen kreisen die glauben damit
tatsächlich
aus meiner sicht auch so was wie
sieht man vieles anders ich rauche man
die eigenen häuser ja viel kleiner was
rednerpult des deutschen bundestags aber
das eigenheim madig gemacht schon im
gerade trotzdem mitarbeiter wähler als
komplett auf das geschlecht zeigen muss
der kanzlerschaft von gerhard schröder
immer finde ich immer fragiler und ich
pipeline ich finde es gibt noch viel
so kommt mir das vor dass er für diese
weitermache in der analyse stimme ich im
gleichen ressort nenne ihn seit er von
vorher jeder überleben können das war
vergaberecht wie beschaffung bürokratie
stunden habe ich mich bei drittel über
druck ausüben zu können auf die
2008 wo und was jetzt
mir soll keiner vorschreiben dass ich so
wissen denn wenn man seinem gegner eine
ist jetzt wieder ein bisschen
oder nach angela merkel naja also wenn
aber mit mattel also als mattel einen
die grundstücksflächen angeht geworden
größeren fehler 2008 beim nato gipfel in
sieht vieles anders aber morgens bereits
dem killer virus gesprochen hat für mich
hergerichtet worden eine milliarde gibt
zug bei denen einer bei den sanktionen
werden ja ich sage trotzdem voraussetzt
kommunikationsprofi ist merkel
den aufgeregt da hat er nämlich
und schnellere schneller werden übrigen
gesellschaft diesem druck muss man
nicht okay deine these ist ja ganz klar
solche solche vorlage gibt dann
zeit so eingesetzt wird und irgendwann
ich mir beispielsweise die
vermisse aber eine nach vorne drängen
getwittert zitat in den usa ist eine
darüber zu reden dass eben gerade was
abgetaucht was können wir denn als
allerdings muss ich sagen das ist
arbeitslosenzahlen wenn ich mir die
drängt ohne die arbeit im ministerium zu
widerstehen ja diesen möglichst band
es wieder gab es wieder die waren sofort
einiger vor in den nächsten
bukarest hat angela merkel dafür gesorgt
mehr jungen mann raus gebracht hat da
sehr spannen uns gesagt hat steiniger
ist die karl zeit vorbei wenn er so
verwandelt er sich natürlich auch aber
auch wir abschaffen und einmal das
wirtschaftszahlen anschaut dann ganz
abschlussfrage zu dieser these von der
bundestagswahl wäre sie im bundestag zu
natürlich eine krasse geschichte aber im
vergriffen heute nach zwei stunden waren
machen wenn nachweisen kann dass da
sie haben gesagt weil es braucht geld
[Musik]
[Gelächter]